[Música]
cuanta gente impresionante que teme un
segundo que ya estoy con ustedes un
segundo nada más
bueno cabeza anda la escuela importante
bien al sexto a la maestra vez dales
después me contás cómo te fue
chau cadista chat para que yo sin email
usa para que vaya y así que bueno esto
es un poco
un chiste un humor y además da mucho
calor pero no importa lo importante
enmarcar es impactar y ahí va el mensaje
me desnudó un poco para ustedes
acá estoy pero que todavía no termine me
tengo que bajar un poco el pantalón que
me apretaba un poquito pero no importa
ahora sí feliz acá estoy buenas buenas
me queda algo más ahora sí ahora estoy
con ustedes esto que fue una cosa de
impacto como broma o chiste tiene algo
de tremendo que ya lo estamos viendo y
escuchando en cada uno con victoria con
carolinas con las dos carolinas
esta cabeza que se fue no se fue pero
quiero que se vaya un ratito más dale al
darte un ratito más me gusta que se vaya
mire hay está ahí se va a la cabeza a la
escuela y de primera contar cómo le fue
pero esto que parece que exagerado les
cuento que no ven ahí le muestro por
ejemplo esta es el aula de la
universidad de trabajo de la un lado ahí
entran mis alumnos miren
ahí están los ven ay me están esperando
pero en realidad con que voy a trabajar
con este mineral
no es tremendo y esto en parte se asocia
mucho con lo que está pasando que cada
vez nos cuesta más y más porque este
modelo de aula que acabamos de ver ahí y
que les muestro acá en esta imagen es un
modelo del siglo 18 de haber escuchado
su modelo porciano un modelo prusiano
del siglo 18 más de 200 años no se puede
creer tenemos la misma aula claro un
aula preparada para que los chiquitos
sentaditos con timbres horarios fijos
nada de creatividad preparados para ir a
una fábrica miren la fábrica y al
costado se parece al aula o peor aún
preparados para ser soldados
y respetará órdenes y matar asesinar
esto es un poco la base de nuestra aula
pueden creerlo todavía
mientras esperamos el cambio áulico que
está viniendo vieron todas las charlas y
todo lo está pasando en el mundo hay una
necesidad tremenda es un problema porque
metas el aula sigue así el niño la niña
el de adolescentes desde que entra
se imagina un reloj pues se quiere ir y
no pasa nunca incluso nosotros nos
esforzamos en enseñar y cada vez se
aprenden menos cada vez nos ponen más
triste de las notas cada vez nos vamos
más tristes del aula cada menos va peor
entonces que vengo a hacer acá desde
buenos aires de vuelta en este país que
me encanta que vengo a hacer tengo este
objetivo tengo el objetivo de mostrarles
por qué es tan importante el cuerpo y el
cerebro y su cabeza para el aprendizaje
y para la enseña ese es mi objetivo y
prepárense porque lo voy a hacer le voy
a dar claves al final para meter cuerpo
pero primero les voy a dar resultados de
la investigación como buen biólogo le
encanta la investigación y miren voy a
empezar el aviador tres resultados de
investigación que me encantan para que
entienda la importancia del cuerpo
cuántos son tres metan cuerpos tres el
tres pide después cuántos eran eran tres
es que el cuerpo te pide hoy cada vez
que participaban les hacía levantar las
manos y ahí largaban el celular
prestación aplaudir se van dando cuenta
la importancia del cuerpo para volver
bueno vamos a 33 experimentos vamos al
primero miren hay
qué animal es ese no es el que viene
nadando es parecido a vino ese animal
que sea y que sabe
sabe
eso es una esponja
una esponja de mar aunque no lo pueden
creer es un animal que está en la tierra
hace 650 millones de años es el primer
ser vivo de millones y millones y
millones de células como nosotros el
primer animal multicelular y que tiene
interés porque lo traje arte es que
tiene que haber una esponja hernán acá
por más biólogo que sea que tiene nada
bueno prepárense porque este animal hay
machos y hembras se reproducen la pasan
bien las esponjas y tienen agujeros por
donde circula el agua y de ahí entra de
alimento si y regulan la velocidad del
líquido incluso si ven una tormenta
cierran los agujeros para que no les
entre arena tienen largas que salen y
nadan y se guían por la gravedad y por
la luz y ahí viene lo loco están
preparados no tiene el sistema nervioso
no tienen cerebro no tienen una [ __ ]
neurona pero que tienen
o sea primer experimento y primer golpe
primero el cuerpo primero apareció el
cuerpo primero apareció el cuerpo y
después seguimos la evolución aparece
esta belleza mire guau las medusas a mi
me picaban cada que metía al mar me
picaba de una y pero las amo miren estas
medusa mira ese movimiento es
maravilloso claro ahí ya aparece el
sistema nervioso aparecen las neuronas
aparecen neuronas sensitivas para captar
estímulos neuronas motoras para mover la
medusa interneuronas
para integrar por eso esa medusa
tiene una interacción con el ambiente
perfecto para eso aparece el sistema
nervioso para que el cuerpo saque más
beneficio del ambiente que lo rodea
obviamente pero el cerebro aparece en
función del cuerpo porque hay un cerebro
centrismo tremendo todo aparece en el
cerebro y el cuerpo entonces las medusas
son en las primeras que tienen sistema
nervioso y si seguimos aparecen los
gusanos los insectos las planarias y
sigue la evolución aparecen los peces
los reptiles las aves si llegamos a los
primates no ahí vienen los primates
aparece el mono y el mono hasta que el
hombre ahí ya el sistema nervioso ha
solucionado tanto que ya ese cerebro
tiene un poder en el ambiente es tan
tremendo que en vez de mejorarlo le
estás destruyendo miren el poder que
tiene el ser humano y su cerebro en vez
de sacarle jugo al ambiente lo estamos
haciendo pelota estamos de acuerdo queda
bien claro entonces el primer
experimento o sea mamá la conclusión ahí
lo tiene pregunta examen que apareció
primero
y después en función del cuerpo para
mejorar mi interacción con él también es
el primer experimento que me encanta
vamos al segundo el segundo se asocia
con estos equipos que aparecen en el 80
en 1080 aparece el resonador magnético
funcional salen carísimos pero tienen la
maravilla de que puedes meter alguien
adentro y ver su sistema nervioso
impecable miren cómo se ve antes había
que esperar que se muriera y sacarle el
cráneo a ver desde el 80 podés ver lo
que hay ahí adentro y lo más loco y más
impresionante se puede ver la función
del sistema nervioso por eso hay tanta
neurociencia ahora tanto éxito porque
aparecen muchos más equipos pero bueno
con este equipo en el 2017 espero en que
me acomodo el micrófono así el cuerpo no
me molesta a la mente mientras el
micrófono esté incomodando me distrae
ver el cuerpo y la mente quién puede
prestar atención a un ats se está
haciendo pis
quien puede prestar atención a ted si
tiene hambre el cuerpo siempre manda
gente dense cuenta si entonces el cuerpo
ahora me va a ayudar y ahora viene esto
un grupo en el 2017 de investigadores
metieron personas adentro del resonador
magnético en medio claustrofóbico pero
igual puedes mover las manos un poco los
pies y los hicieron mover las manos en
los pies para ver cuáles eran las
regiones del cerebro encargadas del
movimiento lo que tienen las funciones
motrices ya quisieron ver cuando uno
mueve el cuerpo qué zona se prende
estamos de acuerdo y se prendieron esas
no importa cómo se llama miren los
colores ahora viene lo más interesante
los investigadores dijeron y dónde están
las funciones cognitivas aprender qué es
una súper función cognitiva amar hacer
música lo que está pasando acá es
cognitivo lo que están entendiendo es
cognitivo entonces se preguntaron dónde
están las funciones cognitivas en el
cerebro
se entiende la pregunta vamos entonces
agarrar las mismas personas y vamos a
ver dónde está les hicieron imaginar
cosas rotar objetos en la mente y miren
lo que apareció
miren las motrices
miren las motoras miren las motrices la
motriz se dije miren las motoras la
motriz las motoras o sea que se
descubrió
qué son las mismas
impresionante
el lugar del cerebro donde tenemos
funciones cognitivas es el mismo lugar
donde generamos el movimiento corporal
incluso donde nos imaginamos un plan
miren qué bueno esto por eso a partir de
ahí sale esto pensar lo cognitivo y el
movimiento es lo mismo para el cerebro
por eso viene una frase para poner en la
ropa se aprende haciendo lo están
escuchando a lo largo de toda la charla
no se aprende sentado y escuchando se
aprende haciendo tienes que meter
músculos cuerpo para aprender no alcanza
con mirar y escuchar se aprende haciendo
sí pero bueno yo les dije que eran tres
experimentos 3 3
cuerpo cuerpo número 3 el tercero me
encanta desde darwin empezaron las
emociones pero en los últimos años las
emociones entraron al aula vieron hay
gente que dice sólo se aprende si hay
emociones escucharon eso la inteligencia
emocional o no pero qué es una emoción
qué es una emoción qué es una emoción
una reacción corporal el cerebro delante
de un estímulo externo o interno genera
un estímulo que genera una emoción no es
cierto el cerebro delante de un estímulo
externo o interno interno qué significa
un estímulo por ejemplo imaginario
si es emocional genera una reacción
corporal y para qué son las emociones
para sobrevivir en el ambiente el
cerebro es una máquina predictiva
encaminado a reducir la incertidumbre
del entorno le gustó esa frase
el cerebro es una máquina predictiva
caminada reducirlas entre hombre del
entorno o sea la gran función del
sistema nervioso es que sobrevivas en el
ambiente pero con éxito no es sobrevivir
solamente es tener cada vez más éxito
entonces para qué son las emociones la
emoción siempre te dice o interactúa o
me escapo entonces cuando en el aula hay
buena onda cuando en el aula hay buena
relación con mis docentes con mi maestra
con mi maestro con mis compañeros me
puedo equivocar no pasa nada no me bajan
la nota no me castigan estoy como
derrick olor en el aula entra la luz veo
la naturaleza como contaban carolina
cuando en esa aula está bueno a mis
emociones son positivas y mi cuerpo
quiere más se abre la pupila se dilata
mi corazón late transpiró molesto quiero
más profe maestra de más me encanta
cuando el aula hay vergüenza ya hay
miedo te castigan el error hay fe dolor
me llevo mal con mis compañeros no
entiendo nada lo que dice el docente de
que está hablando no me pregunta cuánto
se empezó
no entiendo nada por lo tanto mi cuerpo
se mete para adentro se cierra o sea
queda claro y las emociones no son un
invento del cerebro es un invento del
cerebro usando el cuerpo entonces
quedaron los tres experimentos si o no
bueno entonces que vengo a demostrar acá
que para que haya una buena educación
la danza
del cerebro y del cuerpo de que sea
perfecto no como estoy haciendo yo que
es una porquería tienes una danza linda
hermosa si quieren que el alumno aprenda
el cuerpo tiene que danzar con el
cerebro si tiene que avanzar con usted
es bueno y entonces bueno ya está los
experimentos ya está espero verlos
convencidos o no más o menos un poquito
menos bueno vamos a lo que más quieren
ustedes quiero clave darme clares miren
qué animación que hicimos espectacular
bien creo que es impresionante vamos a
claves quiero claves las claves se van a
vivir en dos la primera obviamente en
movimiento real quiero que el alumno se
mueva en el aula hoy todos pasaron por
el movimiento en el nivel inicial
victoria el jugar siempre hablaron del
movimiento parece un eje temático que
por algo viene bien en cómo nos está
costando quedarnos sentaditos la mayor
parte ustedes empieza a rascar se
empieza a cambiar de lugar hace pelito
agarre el celular necesitan moverse
imagínate un niño lleno de energía la
gente necesita moverse para pensar no
podemos ejercen está 2 pero bueno vamos
a la primera cosa cuando yo hablo de
movimientos por favor no es sólo el
muscular no es solo este cuando hablo
del movimiento gente hablo de movimiento
de las vísceras también quiero
taquicardia mis alumnos me encuentro dan
y cuando entró dan y era para pesarlo
porque entró y dijo no sé si me van a
creer lo emocionado que estoy y su sed y
su respiración hacia
la vieron no hace falta que me lo digas
con palabras tu cuerpo me está diciendo
que estás emocionado queda claro la idea
no solo miren músculo miren corazón bien
en respiración temperatura de la mano si
entonces vamos al momento real cómo es
que participe que conteste preguntas
fíjense cómo cada vez los trataron de
hacer participar bailar cantar levantar
la mano cuánto más movimiento de
participación hay en el aula más
aprendizaje hay preguntas si todo el
tiempo participar fíjense que el drama
que tenemos que desde que pensamos el
aula sentimos que no vamos a llegar con
los contenidos bien no nos terminó no
terminó no termina voy a hacer dos o
tres preguntas pero si no no termino no
por favor recuerden que menos es mejor
que mucho y rápido no importa el
contenido tirarlo a la merca sí que
participe el alumno es más importante
que ocupas el contenido que te sientes
liviano pero ya lo digo si el alumno
lente no le estudio el problema de él
no es problema de él si entonces
participar trabajar en grupo trabajar el
grupo se tocan además hemos castigado
tanto el error que cuando el alumno
trabaja en grupo dice total el error es
de todo se libera bien
transit cosa espectacular jugar jugar
pero no desde el nivel inicial jugar si
tocar si yo quiero aprender la te
la toco la tm tocar tocar es mucho más
impactante que mirar o escuchar que
toquen se entiende la idea que jueguen
que toquen que contesten que se muevan
que se ama que el que se llama que él es
el primero el segundo antes del segundo
que quede claro miren esto
yo desde que entró digo chicos esto que
está preguntando todo el tiempo que
están haciendo porque si me están
mirando
miren ahora los estoy haciendo hacer
unas prolongaciones celulares como
biólogo miren las caras de esos chicos
se nos queda claro no vamos al segundo
este
el segundo es espectacular tenemos
dentro del cerebro una región que lleva
neuronas en el espejo y que hace cuando
vea algo que le genera empatía imita el
movimiento pero limita que adentro no en
el cuerpo a veces lo imita de tanta
intensidad que lo representa en el
cuerpo o sea cada vez que delante
nuestro hay una persona que genera
empatía la imitamos corporalmente pero
acá adentro a veces se nos escapa un
poquito entonces vieron una mamá dándole
papilla al bebé
hacer
eso es eso es empatía motora y a donde
quiero llegar
un buen docente tiene que explicar bien
como explican los niños también puede
dejar de mirar a un niño cuando cuenta
algo empezar mira mamá
vemos una casita la casita tenía
chimenea y largaba uno adentro había un
viejo papá noel con barba si el chico te
representa todo con el cuerpo así
tenemos que enseñar lo que llaman claves
ostensiva moviéndonos siendo células
miren qué núcleo que tengo qué bueno qué
tal
siendo células siendo pase montañas
ángulo
a rehenes mensajeros que se meten en la
ribosoma él se entiende todo
[Aplausos]
gracias no me queda claro el piquense
esta frase que me encantó que se da más
yo
todo esto se mete en el cuerpo del
personaje visual y auditivamente y un
buen docente que tiene que ser meterse
en el conocimiento en el cuerpo
incorporar el cuerpo si quieren triunfar
en el aula tienen que ser conocimiento
tienen que soltar se tienen que hacer
magia cansarse salir agotado hacer
piernas es el glúteo eso es enseñar no
estar sentado atrás de un asiento porque
te mueren todos y bueno creo que los
habré convencido
pero roberto me dejó un poquitito y
antes de irme
en esa frase no la mente es el cuerpo y
el cerebro en movimiento quedó claro hay
que poner el cuerpo en la educación es
el objetivo principal pero antes de irme
ahí tienen hay que poner el cuerpo en el
centro de la educación creo que quedó
claro pero antes de irme
como siempre tengo una pregunta
espectacular para hacerles una pregunta
que cuando la aprendí me partió la
cabeza
miren esta estoy apretando cualquier
botón ahí está ahí está la pregunta
cuerpo powerpoint cuerpo power el cuerpo
que impacta más cuerpo o powerball
quedó claro no quedó claro bueno
hermosa de terminar el cuerpo es una
emoción la moción inhibe la cognición no
puedo hablar
pero quieren que pierda cuerpo y vuelve
a la cognición ya está me puse frío
pero somos culpables de que esos niños
niñas adolescentes no quieran aprender
porque vieron que los docentes son
culpables de todos o no y somos
culpables son lo que piensan
bueno les cuento para que se liberen a
ti es un investigador que analizó un
millón y medio de alumnos buscando cuál
es la variable
la variable para que quieran aprender y
que descubrió miren qué bueno que está
que el 50% es el alumno del 100 por
ciento de la variabilidad de querer
aprender el 50 lo trae el su motivación
su gana su interés si comió si se lleva
bien con los compañeros el 50% lo trae
él y el otro 25
son ustedes
y obviamente que hay al docente es
malísimo quien no conoce los walking
dead' de digo yo
está lleno no es obvio que hay docentes
malos pero qué es lo malo de los malos
docentes que ahora están viendo nextel
que deben estar sentados acá o no porque
no son los que van a los congresos o no
[Aplausos]
enorme les agradezco infinito que estén
conmigo acá que hayan pasado toda la
todo el día que quede todo este momento
de estar todo un día con alguien es muy
fuerte y les dejo sólo esto que sirve
realizó pero me encanta
todos los políticos los políticos los
escritores las escritoras hermoso la
moza el músico la música el técnico la
técnica todos pasan por ustedes todos
pasan por haber si nos damos cuenta
todos pasan por ustedes tienen dos
padres pero todos pasan por ustedes y
ustedes deben ser los que cambien los
que los logren ustedes tienen que dejar
marcas en ellos para que este mundo
oscuro dese cuenta usted tiene que dejar
alma tienen que volar les la cabeza y el
cuerpo y el corazón pero lo tienen que
dejar ustedes ahí tenemos la profesión
más bella del mundo yo me puedo morir
súper tranquilo porque camino y me besan
y me abrazan y me agradece digo más que
más quiero aunque gane porque me importa
super feliz así que gracias gracias
atrás
[Aplausos]
[Música]